trigger warnings fail to help and may
even harm aps association for
psychological science so what it says is
really interesting so a few studies that
were done for some traumatic events
leave deep psychological scars that can
resurface many years later as renewed
emotional pain or unwanted memories in
an effort to spare survivors reminders
of past trauma some institutions and
individuals provide so-called trigger
warnings alerts that upcoming program or
texts may contain unsettling content
recently however a growing body of
research has called the question the
effectiveness of trigonomets a new study
published in the journal of clinical
psychological science shines additional
light on this ongoing debate and finds
that trigger warnings offer little to no
help in avoiding painful memories and
perhaps
are even harmful
for the survivors of past emotional
trauma
researchers discovered that trigger
warnings seem to increase the extent to
which people see trauma as essential to
their identity which can worsen the
impact of post-traumatic stress disorder
in the long run
here's a study jones and his colleagues
conducted a randomized experiment among
two groups of people who had experienced
a serious trauma in the past both groups
read a series of literature passages one
group received trigger warnings prior to
distressing passages while the other did
not participants rated their emotions
after reading each passage and also
completed a series of questionnaires at
the end
overall the researchers found that
little statistical differences in the
reactions of both groups neither seem to
be spared emotional impact of reading
the text
whether trigger warnings are explicitly
harmful was less clear though jones and
his colleagues did find the evidence
that trigger warnings increased
the belief that their trauma is an
essential part of a survivor's life
story which research has shown is
counter therapeutic so essentially what
they're saying is let's say we're having
discussions yeah and you give a trigger
warning then they're transported right
back to their trauma before the
conversation has even happened and
therefore any conversation that they
have as a result is filtered through
that lens so of course you're gonna be
more important it's like saying black
people just letting you know we're gonna
be discussing this topic it's like well
now i'm being reminded of my racial
identity or i'm being reminded of my
ethiopian-ness if you keep mentioning it
before every time that's
counterproductive exactly
so
it's important to know this stuff
because we've adopted a lot of new
policies a lot of new ideas without
actually knowing whether or not they
work or they're efficient they sound
great in theory in theory it sounds good
to let people know beforehand that
something true may be coming the problem
is we found that it actually makes
things worse so now we have to rethink
these things and this is what happens
when you're quick to want to make change
because people are suffering understand
people are suffering we need to improve
things but how you improve things
matters just as much as the intent you
understand what i'm saying right like
you can want to help somebody you just
reach for the nearest pot you throw it
on them because you think it's cold
water oil they're dead you feel
me
now with these trigger warnings we've
convinced people that their trauma their
terrible experiences is who they are it
defines them at all times
and i can honestly say that i've had an
experience like that for me personally
and
it made me color every experience to
that lens
it made me have negative interactions
because i was already coming from it
from like this traumatic experience is
is being reflected in these people
that's how that was the prism through
which i saw everything so
it's important for us to look at the
stuff and be like okay maybe this is not
sensible maybe i'm not doing everyone's
service and also for the people who
expect trigger warnings also understand
maybe this is not having the intended
effect that i wanted it to and i need to
stop asking for them all the time i
still think it's appropriate for some
topics because then if the person wants
to they can just leave yeah you do what
i'm saying like i'm going to give a
trigger warning if i'm showing something
graphic or whatever you can choose to
opt out but what's important to note is
that trigger warning doesn't soften the
blow of whatever it is you're about to
witness
no it doesn't stop from this moment i
believe that uh the trigger warning is
really just for me
it's not for you it's for me trigger
warning oh my god hey
hey i want hey there you go that's good
warned you
it's your business if you're here i was
alive
cover your ass cover my eyes i think
most really most professors do it for
that reason it's really to cover my ass
trigger warning
so this is another hey shut up
i wanted you
you stayed
you know the problem with that is in a
society built on empathy and
understanding victims even that may not
be enough
over half of professors say they use
trigger warnings right now over the past
decade there has been extensive debate
on the appropriateness of trigger
warnings particularly in an academic
environment where they have been accused
of promoting censorship other critics
have suggest that trigger warnings may
create an unrealistic bubble free from
negative thoughts which can prepare
students for beyond for life beyond
academia do you mean safe space yes i
have a friend of mine who teaches at a
really prestigious school okay really
really close one thing that she
encounters a lot she gave like reading
assignments to her students so one of
them involved like japanese history
before the like last 200 years
and
the students like some of them
complained and she's like what do you
guys complain about like
there's some like really disgusting
stuff that happened and they complained
and they got upset so she scrapped that
section
but in my head i'm thinking like how can
you ever internalize what's happened
throughout history
if
you're not going to accept that there's
some darkness out there i mean the mere
fact that you get to say trigger warning
is proof of the progress we've made and
the privilege that you're living you get
what i'm saying you need to understand
what what was there before that's what
history is you know what i'm saying so
it affects people academically in the
workplace as well i don't want to work
in a freaking as
a as a history teacher
all right class
uh
i probably hand you a gun so you could
just fire it off
did they work
today we're gonna talk about
people
that were
can you describe their bodily function
jesus christ um
people that can or can't get pregnant
yeah
cause if i say people that could get
pregnant how did they get pregnant
and
i'm
so
yeah sugar warning
and he just went off himself what are
your thoughts i just want to cover my
ass
that's really that that's why i've been
doing this i'm not thinking about all of
that i'm thinking about them like i'm
going to go through the story trigger
warning okay you're one there's gonna be
some up and after that but
yeah it's it's very interesting the fact
that what you said about we are telling
them that
they are
that trauma for the rest of their life
it's what exactly what we're doing so we
can't remind them of of anything that's
around that because it reminds them of
what happened and who they are so yeah
imagine we start this video and all i
say is trigger warnings no title no
nothing no i just say trigger warning
yeah
this may be traumatic to you what do you
start thinking about every every
trauma that i've been through so you
know
this was not even about me no it
was about a kid getting hurt yes funny
and it has nothing and then i'm
triggered right because you're like what
do i have to be triggered about what can
i be true and so you start to think
about the trigger that you had
right
and when it was not even about me that's
crazy
it's like when people start a sentence
and say i don't want to be racist you
immediately go like this is gonna be the
most i heard all week
so anyways i think
like my buddy my buddy eddie king says
in comedy bits like whenever someone
says i'm not i'm not but it's never like
i'm not but i hate cookies it's never
that no no it's never that it's really
you're about to go in yeah you're about
to and i think black people's noses suck
up so much oxygen
no no i'm just curious
how do you stop yourself from swallowing
the whole thing with your big lips
but yes
but it was i digress let us know what
you guys think in the comments below we
want to hear from you
it really sounds like you heard that
before how do you suck up so much
oxygen yeah